[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host paul aka sabina the
teenage wren
and this video we're breaking down our
theories on who sasha banks may be
playing
when the trailer for the mandalorian
season 2 dropped there was a lot of
speculation over who this figure was
and some people thought it was rosario
dawson playing ahsoka
some people thought it was rosie
o'donnell playing ash ketchum
and generally there was a lot of stars
experts who got it wrong
except for me your friendly neighborhood
spoiler man
now there are several characters that it
could be and we believe we've narrowed
it down to the most likely candidates
throughout this video we're gonna be
going through them all and giving you
the
ins and outs that you need to know
before they finally appear in the season
now firstly the most likely candidate
that everyone thinks it is
is sabine wren in case you don't know
the rebels character was a mandalorian
warrior
that helped to spark up the rebellion
and she's an integral part of star wars
lore
as well as being a warrior ren was an
artist that inspired many to join the
rebel cause
and the character currently has a claim
over the dark saber
which we know is in moth gideon's
possession now this is very
important as she has wielded it before
and if the show is slowly trying to
bring everything together
it does make a lot of sense to have her
appear in the season in order to help
take down the imperial villain
season 1 was very much about mando
making a network of allies to help him
protect the child from the clutches of
the imperial warlord
and this time around it makes sense to
bring people across that actually have a
vested interest in his downfall
ren has a very long and rich history
that actually makes her hate the empire
in all forms
and this is because she was part of the
imperial academy growing up
as a cadet ren built weapons that she
believed would be used to restore peace
and order to the galaxy
however these were instead used to
oppress the people of mandalore
and this led to her being completely
wrecked with guilt
wren fled and was branded a traitor by
the empire
and not long after she started working
as a bounty hunter
shortly after this she joined the crew
of the ghost which led to the events
that we saw play out in the first season
of rebels
ren's work made her cross paths with
ezra bridger
and together with the group they started
to sell the seeds that would lead to the
rebellion
on her journeys ren discovered the dark
saber on dathomir
and though she initially didn't want
anything to do with it she eventually
laid claim to it
ren has also teamed up with ahsoka who
it has been theorized as being played by
rosario dawson
this would mean that mando could meet
her through ren and the pieces are
slowly starting to fall in place that
could lead to baby odor
being reunited with his people through
her now while there is doubt over this
actually being the character
is because she doesn't appear with her
mandalorian armor
in the rebels show she was pretty
nonchalant about taking her helmet on
and off
but with it being a hard set rule in the
show i do think that they would carry
this across to keep up the consistency
across the board
she also seems to be hiding out of view
and as we've mentioned
she's actually a big ally of the rebels
so
this doesn't make much sense at this
point in the saga the rebels were
actually at the height of their power
so her hiding away suspiciously seems to
point out that this character's
allegiances
may not actually be with the group like
i said i think that this theory is
probably the most likely one
however there are several other notable
characters that it could be
now if you're enjoying the breakdown so
far then this is probably the perfect
time to subscribe
as we do videos like this every day and
you definitely don't want to miss out
don't forget we're also giving away 3
copies of the marvel phase 2 box set
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below
the win is going to be chosen at random
on the 30th of november
so make sure you get involved now
another possibility is that the
character is actually dr
aphra who up until this point hasn't
appeared in a tv show or movie
however she is heavily laced throughout
the expanded universe
and should it not be ren i definitely
think that aphra is a possibility
now the reason that this could be the
case is because mando is on the lookout
for jedi artifacts
so that he can trace the steps of baby
out as people
aphra is actually an archaeologist who
could potentially point him in the right
direction
and she has had several run-ins with a
jedi as well as darth vader
she was created to be the indiana jones
of the universe
and this saw her going on several
adventures throughout the comics
aphra has a wise cracking attitude and
has pretty much
worked both sides of the fence she has
spent a lot of time with darth vader
and the bear have shared many adventures
together that i definitely recommend you
check
out now because of this aphra is someone
who probably would need to hide in the
shadows
i'm guessing her reputation with the
empire is probably known by the rebels
at this point and though she wasn't
necessarily the one blowing her planet
she would definitely have to keep her
head down aphra was never
really an imperial and she was more
dedicated towards her own agenda
using whoever she could to get by a time
she teamed up with luke han and leia
whilst also working with vader so yeah
she's a very complex character
because i can see her needing to work
with bounty hunters and the like in
order to get by
i do think that this theory does hold a
lot of weight
this would probably put her on the same
path as mando and her appearance here
does slot into the timeline pretty well
as we know the mandalorian takes place
five years after the return of the jedi
so she would roughly be the age that we
see through banks
she's also wearing what looks to be a
jedi hood similar to the one that luke
dons in return of the jedi
and as the character is massively
interested in the religion
this definitely makes sense however this
could also hint that the character
may actually be an inquisitor like aphra
these are featured in the expanded
universe quite a bit
and in case you don't know who they are
they're basically force sensitive
soldiers that were tasked with tracking
down the jedi who escaped order 66.
they featured heavily in rebels and
fallen order
but since the empire was defeated we've
kinda lost track of what happened to
them
now they could be out there in the
galaxy and it's easy to see why mando
may think that one of them is a jedi and
try to join up with them
we actually see in the trailer that
sasha's character quickly disappears
and this would be well within her skill
set now if this
is indeed an inquisitor it isn't very
good news for baby yoda
and the character would likely try and
kill him which would mean that mando
would have to go
toe-to-toe with a lightsaber-wielding
villain this is something that has felt
absent in the show so far
and i would definitely love to see him
face off against someone with the skills
and powers of a sith lord
now similar to this sasha may also be
playing a darth vade occultist
and reddit user the ninja whippet
spotted that the darksaber and darth
vader's lightsaber
were used in the logo for season 2. the
post talks about the acolytes of the
beyond
namely a woman that traveled to terrace
in order to obtain the weapon
taras actually looks very similar to the
planet that we see the character on
and it does line up now this is quite an
obscure theory
but once you start really digging into
it it does make a lot more sense
and lastly the character could be
someone that we haven't encountered
before
we all know the mandalorian likes
bringing people in that we haven't met
and it is completely possible that this
is a brand new character
who isn't pulling from any of the
established law this would make sense as
to why who she's playing hasn't been
fully leaked yet
and with us getting reveals early on
that boba fett and
cobb vance would be in the season it
does seem likely that this would have
made the internet too
so so basically our options are sabine
wren
dr aphra an inquisitor an acolyte of the
beyond
or absolutely anyone in the entire
galaxy
as i said i still think that it's wren
but heaven knows
i've been wrong every day of my life the
season is clearly making ties with
rebels though
due to the crimex in the last entry but
where it's gonna go
i guess we'll have to see obviously i'd
love to hear your thoughts on who you
think this is
so make sure you comment below and let
me know if you enjoyed this video then
please drop a thumbs up
and make sure you check out our
breakdown of the second episode which is
going to be linked at the end
we go through all the ins and outs of
the entry so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more
if you want to support the channel and
get to see contents early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat is on the discord
server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been paul i'll
see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you